everything that we have heard and know
about the X-Men entering the MCU is all
starting to come together and now we are
actually getting news from Marvel
Studios themselves what is going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and perhaps
one of the most exciting things about
the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is the X-Men and if you're not
really sure about what Marvel studios's
plans are for the X-Men in the MCU this
is the video for you we'll break down
exactly what they are planning and how
they are going to pull it off in the MCU
from Multiverse of Madness Professor X
showing up to Deadpool 3 to Dr Strange 3
to Secret Wars and after the future of
the MCU is the X-Men but that future is
starting now in the Multiverse Saga now
for a while now we've heard rumors that
Kevin foggy plans on bringing back the
original X-Men from the original Fox
X-Men movies yes they did confirm Hugh
Jackman was going to be returning as
Wolverine but we had heard that
basically everyone was coming back now
of course a lot of people didn't want to
get their hopes up and still don't
rightfully so considering what we went
through with Multiverse Madness
expecting massive and mini cameos in
which we didn't really get them to an
extent the Illuminati was fantastic but
not a lot of true Multiverse jumping so
after that fans don't really want to get
their hopes up thinking that we're going
to be getting a bunch of cameos in
Deadpool 3 or any other Multiverse Saga
film well Marvel Studios has basically
come out and confirmed we are indeed
going to be getting them in the MCU and
this is only the start of Marvel
studios's plan and Kevin feige's plan
where the X-Men and the MCU let's go
over what Sean Levy the director of
Deadpool 3 for Marvel Studios has
recently said about the X-Men coming to
the MCU he made it pretty clear that
Deadpool 3 is going to include the fox
X-Men Legacy he said Deadpool and
Wolverine are iconic Marvel characters
more specifically iconic Marvel of the
fox era care characters we're not going
to pretend oh we snap our fingers and
suddenly the fox Legacy doesn't exist
and it shaped a lot of what we now know
as the MCU FOX also shaped Ryan's career
Hughes career and my career so there's a
lot of history there and there's a lot
of Marvel history at Fox and certainly
that's part of our storytelling so that
is coming directly from Sean Levy the
director of Deadpool 3 and he basically
just confirmed yeah we're not ignoring
the fox Legacy we are not ignoring the
other X-Men characters we are going to
bring them into this movie and it sounds
like he's almost planning to honor what
they did in the past over at Fox with
the X-Men which honestly should be done
because they really did start it off and
those original movies are classic and
iconic and for a lot of us there are
childhood so honoring them before they
go away and we say farewell is a great
idea and that is Kevin feige plan we
have heard for a while now that Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios is
taking the Multiverse Saga and
specifically Avengers Secret Wars as a
great opportunity to bring these
characters into the MCU for the first
time because remember nothing was really
connected in these movies the old X-Men
movies weren't connected to the
Spider-Man movies or the Daredevil film
or a lecture Etc so all of these
characters and actors unfortunately back
then did not have the opportunity to be
a part of a connected universe but now
that Kevin feige is in charge and
remember Kevin feige started with the
first X-Men movie and pretty much worked
on every movie since then so he knows
everyone as far as the actors are
concerned so now he can bring those
characters and those people that he
knows and loves into this universe to
say farewell properly that is what we
have heard his plans are however we have
also heard that there are some deaths
coming so it looks like some of those
farewells might not exactly all be
peaceful we'll talk about these deaths
in just a bit but first big thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you may know that I personally
use hellofresh and I love it it makes
cooking fun easy and it's affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit delivered straight to your door
and you might not know that they
actually have seasonal recipes right now
since it's summer they have their new
fresh and fit summer menu so if you're
trying to get that beach bud but you're
also trying to eat really great tasting
food it's perfect for you right now it's
peak time for summer produce and
hellofresh make sure you get all the
best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus fifteen percent
off the next two months that's
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months so speaking of the deaths
yesterday we did a video talking about
how The Insider my time to shine hello
has teased that secret Wars really is
going to be what we think and hope it's
going to be cameos Galore with a lot of
old Legacy Fox X-Men characters
appearing in secret Wars they posted a
picture of a fan poster stating this is
what secret Wars is gonna be like on it
is Tobey Maguire Spider-Man Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine we have Daredevil a
Punisher Ghost Rider the original
Fantastic Four blade some of the X-Men
this is really what Kevin feige and
Marvel Studios have planned and that's
fantastic however today The Insider can
we get some toast stated in a reply to
that tweet and poster pretty much
although some of those Fox vs Marvel
characters won't be making it out of
Deadpool 3. so as Sean Levy the director
of Deadpool 3 basically confirmed the
cameos are going to start with Deadpool
3 from what we have heard the TVA is
essentially going to create a battle
World from the comics Avengers Secret
Wars battle World basically from what
we've heard the TVA win the Multiverse
is going to start collapsing and
incursions start happening is going to
go to different universes and take
certain characters and save them from
those collapsing and dying universes and
put them all on one combined Earth in
one universe so we're going to
essentially have battle world one world
where a bunch of people from a bunch of
different universes are gathered and
this sounds amazing however we should
not assume that all of these characters
are going to get along in fact we should
definitely assume that they are not
going to get along especially if you
have characters like Magneto Sabertooth
and especially if you have variants of
the same character think about Magneto
fighting with another Magneto and just
simply good characters fighting against
Bad characters imagine if we had a
Magneto and a Doctor Doom and they
wanted two different things well chances
are they're probably gonna fight plus
not to mention Deadpool and Wolverine
from what we've heard are gonna get
pretty bloody as well we know they're
gonna get pretty bloody with each other
but let's face it in the previous
Deadpool movies we watched Deadpool Kill
A lot of people and we've basically
heard that a Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe version is going to happen in
Deadpool 3 but it's going to be a
Deadpool kills the fox universe so some
of these X-Men are going to probably say
goodbye at the hands of Deadpool and
keep in mind it's probably not just
going to be the X-Men obviously they're
going to be a big part of it but the
original Fantastic Four could show up in
this film as well and variants of other
characters that we might not have seen
yet could show up however even if some
characters die in Deadpool 3 I don't
think that will officially be the end in
fact even if they die in Deadpool 3 I'm
pretty sure they'll still return an
Avengers Secret Wars and this will be
when Kevin feige true really has a
chance to say goodbye to them perhaps
when all is said and done at the end of
Avengers Secret Wars and Kang is
defeated hopefully and it's time to
return to respective universes that's
when we get our big emotional farewell
to these Legacy characters who paved the
way for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
many insiders have said Secret Wars will
be a tribute and a farewell to these old
characters and I personally can't wait
to see it but then after Secret Wars the
fun begins because that's when the new
X-Men the New Mutants of the MCU arrive
based off of everything that we've heard
so far everything from now till Secret
Wars is about the old previous X-Men
perhaps with a little bit of new mixed
in there with some variants but then
after Secret Wars it's all about the new
X-Men and hopefully we start like the
Avengers started hopefully we start with
individual stories and origin stories
for these characters and they eventually
build up to a complete X-Men team
hopefully that's what we have in store
but go ahead and let us know your
thought thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below how do you feel
about some of the original X-Men
possibly dying in Deadpool 3 do you want
to see this do you not let us know don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on the MCU
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month only four days left in this
month to enter you can also find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof